tell us about a typical day in your life
before the crowdfunding campaign for
shoots you wanna start okay so what we
both are really busy anyway we both have
full-time jobs 40 hours a week for both
of us and in some cases my case in
particular like i'll do 60 hours
sometimes so I mean there's a lot that I
was already kind of doing um you know
when we come home from work but now it's
just been a matter of like fitting
everything into it look what let's say
with before so I mean here you are you
working 40 hours a week how are you sort
of balancing that schedule and sort of
fulfilling the creative drive that you
have within you it's I think it's um
it's having a fortunate enough to have a
job where I can I can balance it out
it's not um completely um it doesn't
take up all my time well there's a
little more flexible in the sense that i
have to get when there's something that
needs to be done i have to get it done
but that can fluctuate so you know that
can be a normal 40 hours or it can it
can be 60 hours recent which was
actually a recent change so it was it
was a the most awesome and bad timing
ever to get a new a new position at work
or suddenly you know i'm up till one or
two in the morning trying to finish
something for a deadline and then still
hoping to sneak in a post forum for the
crowdfunding which show which has been
an adventure and i think before was a
good where at least able to take a few
breaks you know where it was like okay
you can use your lunch to have lunch or
you can use the drive home to drive home
and listen to the radio but nap but you
know it's like that that in retrospect
now seems like such a luxury because now
it's been a matter of sort of sitting at
like cramming every second into your
carving something into every second
because we just don't have the time I me
given our work schedules and given you
know the campaign
Ben I can't you can't take that time
like every single second is now thinking
about something else or doing something
else yeah and so I think before the
campaign we tried to be very structured
to get in the film stuff so we both
cover jobs you know I might be able to
do some writing or be online during
lunch and then we come home and you know
I'd be like okay certain days i have my
writing like writing nights certain
hours or go to a certain days our cafe
days other nights we take completely off
just to make sure you know we have that
free time um any type of structure since
Kaponi has kind of been thrown out the
window it's it's an every literally
every waking moment kind of thing now
all right no wait keep it there's not
that many sleeping moments either though
so
you